Hello, this is Lynne. Someone on the other side of this. Hey [inaudible].
So a couple months ago, our producer Lynn Levy,
did an interview with this woman. Yeah, her name is Margaret. Love it. Yes.
And this was Margaret's first time doing a radio interview.
Magic voice. This is so fun.
But this was definitely not her first time talking into a microphone. One, two,
three, four. This is the yellow mine. Two, three, four.
This is the orange mark almost exactly right.
50 years ago. The following recording was made on November,
1919 64 at 2100 hours.
Margaret was at the center of this amazing, weird experiment.
Yeah. Who were you at bedtime like? What were you like? Well,
I've always had a bit of, if everybody's going left, I'll go right.
She Tried College for Awhile, Tulane University for a year,
but she dropped out and I was 20 or 19 or something at that point and moved to
St Thomas in the Caribbean. Had never been turned Ireland,
got a job at this hotel, did menus, checked people in and out.
And one day she hears about the strange research facility on the other side of
the island. And I thought, I wonder what that is about.
And I asked a few people and they said, oh no, no,
they don't like people there can't go there. And I was told not to go there.
So I went there
[inaudible]
and that's how it all started.
That's how we're going to start this show. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich today on radio lab,
a producer Lynn Levy brings us a couple of close encounters.
Although not with aliens. No, it's not.
It's not an outer space cause it's much closer to home in this case.
Although they are kind of alien like yes, but alien life, uh, not Lynne,
a dolphin that's shows about dolphins.
Hey, we're calling this hour. Hello.
So when Margaret got to this mysterious place,
there were dolphins there and uh, the,
what happened was she ended up becoming roommates with a dolphin.
Do you mean in the like Bed-Stuy one bedroom apartment sense? Sort of. Yeah.
She did end up living with a dolphin for,
for many months in this,
apart by a department partner,
had a little desk,
had a little kitchen area with a stove and it was a little tube burner stove or
something and a pot and a tea kettle.
But the thing that's a little bit weird about the apartment is that whole
apartment,
it was filled with water was completely fill in. Well I wasn't a submerge,
but I was in water up mid thighs, sort of is flooded
with water just about there so she could share it with this dolphin.
A young male, Peter, Peter.
Peter was a 10 foot long bottlenose dolphin, young adolescent male.
And he lived there with Margaret and like he would, um, you know,
he could like swim under the desk and uh, there was a balcony,
like swim out onto the balcony and balcony was flooded to the balcony was also
flooded. Yeah, it's really cool. And what was the idea? I mean,
to try and study the dolphin to study the dolphin, um, first of all,
and take a lot of notes, extensive notes. Did you have waterproof paper? No,
I had a typewriter on this board hanging from the ceiling or they also had
microphones everywhere. And specifically the tasks she was given.
I was to teach Peter to speak English.
I she was supposed to teach the dolphin English. Yup.
Really? Well, I mean this was John Lilly's project.
[inaudible]
just for some context,
you know how people get all like a little bit crazy these days about dolphins.
They have like, you know,
shirts with dolphins and necklaces with dolphins and everybody has like dolphin
hairbands, dolphin, black light posters, right.
So this all kind of sort of comes from this Guy John Lilly,
who was a a scientist, a researcher starting in the forties
total rights stuff, physics major kind of guy out of cal tech,
a man's man. According to Grand Burnett, I'm a historian of science.
But then according to Graham, John Lilly has this epiphany
during the second world war.
At the time people just weren't thinking that much about dolphins in general.
Like there was not this idea that they were sort of extraordinary beings.
They were just like big dumb fish, know they were shot for sport.
So John Lilly is doing this, um,
research about brain mapping and he ends up working with dolphins.
And one the,
the story that he's told goes that he was experimenting on these dolphins and as
he's working with them, you know, kind of like shoving things into their brains.
They make noises as would anyone.
And when he listens back to the noises which he's recorded,
it sounds to him like the dolphins are trying to speak to him to say something
to him in not in a non, in a dolphin any way,
but in a human way. Like trying to speak English to him. Really. Yeah.
What did he say the Dolphin was trying to say to him?
I don't think that we know that,
but it sounded to him enough like human speech that he,
he thought like something's going on here. This is important.
According to Graham, he's said later that it made him realize like women, not
the only intelligent organisms out there,
like we have company that maybe humans are what happens when high intelligence
evolves in an animal that also has hands and dolphins are what happens when
comparably if not still more extravagant intelligence evolves in an animal
without hands. What do hands get you? Well,
hands basically get you an appetite for uh, punching people in the head.
Know it, it makes us tool users, but the distance between, uh,
you know, the hammer that you use to uh,
knock open your coconut and the hammer that you use to knock open the head of
that other cro-magnon you were never that keen on is um, in fact, zilch.
There's no difference at all.
By the time you get to the 60s with, you know, like peace and love.
It was exciting to think that the dolphins and the whales have these huge
brains, but they don't, like, they're not after anything.
They're not doing anything with it. They're not trying to hurt anybody.
They're not building cities. They're just being,
and keep in mind,
this is on the verge of the Vietnam War where you have all this anxiety about to
the overpopulation, environmental destruction.
What have they done to our system?
So very quickly the dolphins become like this vision.
We might ourselves be so different than we'd come to feel we were tragically.
Does that make sense?
So John Lily was one of the first people to get swept up in all this.
He quits his government job, moves to the Caribbean and sets up this lab,
John Lily's communication research institute to try to talk to dolphins,
which is where Margaret ended up. And my feeling was this or that.
Everybody was talking about how bright they were and how smart they were.
And it was often Stauffers dolphins. And then it was, it was the hot topic.
And yet every day everybody at that building would get in their car and go home.
Yeah, on a foot. What is that? So she volunteered to stay. Yeah. Yeah.
Her bed was on this kind of wooden platform. In the middle of the apartment,
I was maybe two and a half,
three inches above the water and Peter was right there and Peter could flip me a
little water and wake me up at any point. And that was the whole point of it.
I mean, this wasn't just sleep all night and then, excuse me,
work in the day and then sleep again all night and then do some work in the day.
I might as well go home. Yeah. So I eventually, um,
I didn't really shave my head, but I buzzed it,
whatever it's called now really close because any, you know,
the hair getting wet thing in the middle of the night was very annoying. Yeah,
of course. So I just got rid of her hair and that was helpful.
And then when Peter would come and squirt some water or want to play or throw
something at me,
then I could just roll off this elevator into the water and be with him and do
whatever she says. He was fascinated by the things she brought with her,
a piece of cloth, a teabag. Teabag was a fascinating thing.
I drank,
I drink tea and the tea bag would fall into the water and he would come and get
it. And Sonar it a,
this creaking noise they make on their sonar.
You need look at it and take the string over his beak and sort of whim around
very proudly with this teabag.
And then he'd throw it up against the wall and it would stick.
And then he'd squirt water on it and it would come back down into the water and
he would play with his teabag. Eventually,
of course he would bite it is very sharp teeth. Yeah. And it would break.
And that was a very exciting thing when the teabag finally broke open,
it had babies, as it were,
zillions of tea leaves floating around and he was sonar them all and want to
count every single one of them.
[inaudible]
and what did you think you would find out? I didn't know.
You know,
I was not coming out at this from a science point of view that that's not what I
was bringing to the table. Yeah. I just, I just, I just, I had no idea. I,
I was, uh, programmed by, by John to work on the speech,
a I all, he had sort of declared that,
that they could probably speak
hi.
Look when, when you're trying to have a conversation with someone.
Yeah.
You do listen,
one person speaks and the other one listens and then you're speaking and I
listen. And people sort of normally do that back and forth.
But when you start with a dolphin making airborne sounds,
once they get the idea, this alumnus really, it goes off
every show offy and they want to override you.
Okay. So you have to spend a lot of time getting it down to,
I'm talking now and now it's your turn.
Huh?
Now have you had a Fuze upset about something? He'll overnight
paid her and it's annoying.
Yeah. Listen again.
Yeah.
Hey, what's this? Come on Peter. One, two,
three.
[inaudible]
that started me in one, two, three.
yes, but he learned very quickly to listen to me. One, two, three,
four.
[inaudible]
good.
And not to pick up my instructions if I would say no, no, no,
Peter, I don't want you to do that. I want you to do this, this,
this, Huh? He would give me back this, this,
this parrot will often say, no, no, no, probably want to crack her.
They will Pete, the whole thing of whatever you said. Huh.
But Peter Wood would pick up what I wanted when he was being a good student and
he was a good student. There seemed to be
with this one dolphin anyway, can be for all of them. An interest in,
in what we were doing. He wanted to practice, he wanted to get it right.
He a, there was a mirror and he would spend long periods of time by himself.
Didn't want me to be part of it.
And he would practice whatever it was we had been doing in the lesson that day
over and over and over and over. He wanted to get it right
out. Ah, ah, ah,
sorry. Oh, and he,
he would work at that for no reason. He's not getting fish.
I'm not interacting with him and nothing. He just wants it. Right.
Like doing homework, like homework. Exactly.
And after a few months of this, why
[inaudible]
Peter did start to sound really different.
One, two
[inaudible]
one, two, three.
[inaudible].
Hello.
He kept getting better. It's extremely difficult for them though.
Hello?
They just have a blow hole. They,
they do not have the apparatus to the SS are almost impossible.
Uh, I would feed him my name all wet and m is very hard.
He would eventually roll over almost into the water with the blow hole to muffle
called Grit.
Okay.
I love the thing. Really. You're saying he would,
he would use the water as a way to help him make the sound.
Yes. All work with that word.
[inaudible]
oh, and,
and we knew that was your name.
Aw.
I don't know. But nevertheless, we were a pretty good match.
He, I, I, I knew his mood, his temperament, and he, and he knew mine.
He knew when I was sick and I would get sick. I mean,
you were in the water all the time. You're bound to get a cold or something. He,
he just loved my anatomy. He wanted to know what my knees were doing.
He would go behind my knee and sonar and look at it and feel it and push it and
find out which way it would go. He just, and I gave him the time
cause I wasn't going home, uh, to, to look at my knee,
to look at my feet. He was enormously interested,
oddly enough in the space between my fingers.
Really not the fingers so much, but he would, I mean, you know,
his be could just barely fit there,
but he wanted to put in between each finger and see what that was all about.
The same with the toes. He didn't have any spaces anywhere. He, you know, he,
he had solid flippers but no space in between them.
Do you think he was so interested in your fingers and toes because he didn't
have any? Yes, I do.
Margaret and Peter ended up spending about nine months living together,
but towards the end things kind of started to, first of all,
there weren't really results from this experiment.
They never were able to publish any scientific papers and there were other
problems. Lily got very involved in drugs, especially
LSD. He did bring it down.
He did a give LSD. He says he did.
I believe him to, to, to have that all his,
I would not let him give LSD to Peter. I wouldn't allow that.
Why would he give him lst?
Well it's not a hundred percent clear but it seems like he was trying to find a
way to get the dolphins to open up to connect,
maybe to talk in any case by 1965 66,
his funding had started to dry up. And when people heard about Margaret's work,
they tended to focus on like one particular part of the story.
You don't have to answer, but a lot has been made of your, uh,
sort of sexually engaging with Peter. And I just want to ask,
cause you don't seem like a shrinking violet. I just want to ask,
is there anything you want to say about that?
Um, what would I like to say about that? I think
the sensational side of it is, yeah.
Is, here's what Margaret told me. Peter was a young dolphin,
he was horny and he would hump her leg a lot, kind of like a dog might do,
which was getting in the way of their work.
So eventually I just said the heck with it and she used her hand to, you know,
and,
and it would quickly satisfy them and then we could go back to doing what we
were doing. And I, I never really gave it another thought. I never thought, Oh,
don't let anybody know. I never thought, oh, this shouldn't be.
But because of details like this and the drugs,
this experiment became extremely controversial,
almost untouchable. People didn't want to be associated with Lilly.
Nobody wanted to fund anything that sounded like Lilly.
It just got this like aura of don't go there,
don't go there.
Even people who wanted to do really rigorous work with human dolphin
communication had a tough time getting any funding.
And that lasted for a long time.
And the thing is, even though there are so many reasons to disapprove of
this experiment, when you talk to Margaret,
you can't read each other's company,
but want to be in that apartment with them.
He would come over and when he was in what I call his sweet mood,
and Peter had a lot of very, very sweet mood to him.
He would sink to the bottom and take my foot in his mouth.
And he wasn't sonar aring and he wasn't looking at anything.
It was almost like a little kid comes and just wants to hold your hand.
And he would just sink to the bottom and close his eyes and just hang onto my
foot.
Okay.
And then you'd have to come up and breathe and then you'd go back down and he
just grabbed my foot
[inaudible]
and he would do this for a good while.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
we'll be back in a moment with another encounter.